Hi, welcome back. Now that we've talked
about all of the different investment
philosophies from stock picking to
market timing, from value to growth,
from information trading to arbitrage,
we're going to come back full circle and
ask the question, should we be even
trying to beat the market? Should we be
buying actively trying to pick stocks
and time the market? And in this
session, the push back begins on active
investing. So to see how active
investing has come under assault in the
last three decades, maybe four decades,
take a look at this graph. This graph
here's what you see. You see active
investing in all of its different forms,
equity, mutual funds, hedge funds, etc.
And it looks at index funds and ETFs,
which are passive investing vehicles. It
cost you almost nothing to invest in an
index fund. You put your money in there.
and it looks at the percentage of
overall money in the market that comes
from active and passive sources. If you
look at ETFs and index funds, they used
to be almost none of the market in the
in the I know index funds were create in
the 1970s, but they were a tiny segment
of the market. And over the last 40
years, here's what you've seen. You've
seen active investing's market share go
from close to 100% 94 95% in the 1980s
down to about 35%
in 2024.
That's a pretty substantial change
you've seen over time in the growth of
passive investing. And this has given of
course active investing active investors
a whole lot to worry about. and there
and it raises questions about what it is
that's causing the shift.
I think the reason is very simple. The
case for passive investing, investing in
index funments and ETFs is made by
active investors and how they performed
relative to the market. As you will see
in the rest of the session, the history
of active investing reflects a reality
which is active investing collectively
has failed to deliver on its pro promise
and has actually underperformed the
market. We'll talk about both the data
and the intuition as to why that might
be. But there are two subsegments or two
questions you need to address in active
investing. Before we turn to mutual fund
managers and hedge funds and all the
rest of the active investing players,
you can ask about individual investors.
You can say, well, maybe they fail for
other reasons, but I am an individual
investor. What is the history of
individual investors with the market?
We'll start with that, but then we'll
turn to professional money managers and
see if their record is different, better
or worse than individual investors.
Let's start with what individual
investors do relative to the market. The
overall evidence looking at individual
individual investors is the average
individual investor does not beat the
market. And in fact, the more they
trade, the lower their returns tend to
be. The more active they are, the lower
their returns tend to be. and pooling
individual investors into investment
clubs or today in social media doesn't
yield better returns. So the overall
evidence on individual investors is they
don't beat the market
but there is a glimmer of hope. There's
a subset of individual investors who
seem to beat the market and what they
share are the common first. They stay
with what they know, stay local, stay in
businesses they know and perhaps that's
where the competitive advantage becomes
and the winners win big. The top 10% of
tra traders outperform the bottom 10% by
a huge amount. So there's some
individual investors who do beat the
market. The answer is yes. Do they do it
because they're lucky or because they're
skillful, it's tough to know. This is a
game where separating luck luck from
skill is is difficult to do. But the
fact that they exist is good news for
individual investors who keep trying.
You see, what about professional money
managers? At least in theory, they
should be better informed, have smarter,
have more data, bigger, better tools
than individual investors do, right? And
at least in theory, they should earn
higher returns than individual investors
and have better odds of beating the
market. The data doesn't back that up.
In fact, the earliest study of money
managers
was in the 1960s when Michael Jensen,
who was then teaching at the University
of Chicago, took 120 plus mutual funds.
That's how many mutual funds there were
in the US. And he asked a very simple
question. How much does the average
mutual fund manager beat the market by?
The reason he framed that question that
way was the conventional wisdom in the
60s was professional money managers no
more have better tools. And let's face
it, in the 60s they have advantages over
the rest of us. Therefore, they must do
better than the rest of us. And what he
uncovered remains one of the most
sustained findings in finance. He found
that the more than 60% of mutual fund
managers closer to 70% actually
underperformed the market and the
average mutual fund manager
underperformed the market by about 1 to
one and a 12%.
That difference he got by comparing what
they earned to what they should have
earned given the risk and given what the
market did. He called Jensen's alpha. He
called it alpha but it became called
Jensen's alpha. And to this day in
active investing that word hangs in
there. alpha captures how much a mutual
fund manager or a money manager makes
over and above what they need to make
given the risk they want to take on. So
Jensen's finding was that mutual funds
don't beat the market. They
underperformed by about 1 to one and a
half%.
Now a little later in the process,
people looked at bond funds and there
the finding remained the same. The
active bond fund underperformed an index
of bonds by about 20 to 30 basis points.
both stock and bond funds when actively
managed by professional managers
underperformed indices. Now of course
when um this evidence was first
presented to active money managers their
response was it must be something in the
model that they used that the you know
the Michael Jensen for instance used the
capital asset pricing model to come up
with expected returns. So the push back
was maybe the model is wrong. Maybe we
do beat the market and you're you're
coming up with your results because your
risk and return models are wrong. So
over the last 40 years, people have
tried variance or no model at all.
You're saying what does that mean? You
can compare the returns that active
money managers make
to just the S&P 500, right? And look at
what percentage beat the market.
If you think about it, at least 50%
should beat the market, right? I mean in
any given period and if you look across
the last 25 years in this century look
at that that statistic this is a so that
you can't blame risk and return models
this is the percentage of equity fund
managers who beat the S&P 500 there have
been only what a few years a handful of
years where that number is higher than
50%. In most years,
the index beats the average equity
mutual fund manager. And if you decide
to bring in other ways of controlling
for risk within the CAPM, of course, we
talked about the sharp ratio, the
trainer measure, the Jensen's alpha,
they all indicated underperformance.
When people try to arbitrage pricing
models, the conclusion remained the
same. In fact, as you look across 40
years of trial and error with different
risk and return models, you might get
variance on how much you get as an ex as
in your finding. But across these
models, the conclusion seems to be the
average active money manager doesn't
beat the market.
Now, we also in the context of risk and
return talked about proxy models where
people brought in market cap and price
to book. Now before these proxy models
entered the game there was a simple way
in which a mutual fund manager could
beat the expected return. You invested
overinvested in small cap stocks or low
price to book stocks. The last century
you look like you beat the market after
controlling for risk not because you
actually beat the market but because of
a failure in the model. And it was in
response to that underperformance by
risk and return models that you start to
get proxy models where you brought in
factors to come up with expected
returns. Now what happens when you use
these models to look at active money
managers? It turns out that active money
managers who artificially beat the model
no longer do that you can't just do this
by buying small cap stocks. In fact, in
1997, one of the most widely cited
mutual fund studies, Carheart used a
four factor model, beta market cap,
price to book, and price momentum. And
he concluded the average mutual fund
manager underperformed the market by
about 1.8% a year. That's why I call
this one of the most persistent findings
in finance that the average active money
manager underperforms an index by about
1 and a half to 2%.
Now along the way, one of the things
people noticed about these studies that
was actually biased in favor of active
money managers was failing to account
for the fact that if you're a bad money
manager, over time you tend to cease to
exist. There's a survivor bias. Now,
Carart in his 1990s study actually
chronicled how much of a survivor bias
there was by looking at how many funds
failed or ceased to exist. And he found
that over his period 3.6% 6% of funds
failed to exist. You're saying each year
3.6% of funds failed and that many of
these funds were the worst performing
funds. So if you didn't allow for the
survivor bias, if you just looked at
mutual funds in existence today and work
backwards, you're likely to overstate
the performance of mutual funds by
about.17%.
In fact, the greater the survivor
problem, the more bias this creates. We
talked about this in the context of
hedge funds where an even larger
percentage fail on an annual basis. So
the bottom line is you can't blame
overall mutual fund performance on
models or periods across time. Active
money managers have had trouble matching
up to the market. Now of course active
money managers come in lots of different
forms, right? Variety of styles. You can
be a value money manager, f a growth
money manager, large cap, small cap
stocks. You can also be a small fund and
a big fund, domestic funds, foreign
funds. So the question, if you're an
active money manager, is there a glimmer
of hope? Is there a subset of money
managers who do beat the market? And I'm
going to give away the bad news before I
even show you the data. No, there is no
good news. When you look at small cap,
you know, mutual fund manager invest in
small cap and large cap stocks and you
compare them to their relative indices.
So you take the small cap funds and you
compare them to small cap index. Large
cap funds and you compare them to large
cap index. Across time at least
you look at the percentage of money
managers who beat the market. Slightly
better odds with small cap funds and
large cap funds but only you know in
individual years. Across time both small
cap and large cap cap funds have
struggled to beat the market. There have
been individual years where both groups
have beaten the market. But across time,
neither small cap nor large cap funds
have had more than 50% beat the market.
So this is a comparison to the index.
It's a very clean comparison. If I want
to invest in small cap stocks, I can
either buy the index fund or I can buy
an active small cap fund manager. And
historically, I'd have been better off
buying the index fund. You're saying,
what about value versus growth, midcap,
large cap? This is um this is a graph
that I pulled out of SPA which is a S&P
site which does an incredible service.
They compare active money managers to
the market and they control for styles
by comparing to an index based on the
stats. If you're a value manager, they
compare you to value index, a growth
manager to growth index and they
chronicle a very simple statistic. What
percentage of managers are outperformed
by the market? See those pie charts?
See the orange part of the pie charts?
That's the percentage of money managers
who are outperformed by the index.
That's astonishing number, right? 90%
93% large cap growth funds 100% of the
active money managers are outperformed
by the index. No matter how you slice
and dice active money managers, there
isn't a segment or a style that seems to
beat the market.
Now over the last few years, Piva has
expanded its search across the globe and
they chronicle in each part of the globe
what percentage of active money managers
are beaten by the market. I'll tell you
the story why this makes you know this
the answer or the the question to which
this analysis responds. Is there a
bigger payoff to active investing in a
market where information is tougher to
get where a market that's you know an
emerging market without much of history
in investing? You could tell a story
that if you're investing in a country
where there's not much history of
investing that a professional money
manager might do better. There's very
weak evidence of that happening. There
only two parts of the world where active
money managers
beat the index more than 50% of the
time. One in South Africa 42 49 47. So
barely you know barely above 50%. And in
the Middle East where at least for the
long term so the three numbers are one
year, 5 year and 10 year. If you go to
the long term in the Middle East, you
you lose. But in the short term, money
manage active money managers beat the
index in every other part of the world.
Oh, and Mexico and for whatever reason
and made again it's very similar to the
Middle East. In the short term, money
managers win. In the long term, not so
much. In every part of the world, if you
go to that 10-year, the long-term, in
every part of the world, the indices
beat active money managers. And it's not
just stocks. If you do this with bonds
and you compare active bond funds to
bond indices, again, every slice of
active bond investing, short-term,
long-term, governments, corporates,
every kind of fund, you find the index
beating an active money manager. So,
here's the bottom line. And it's not
good news if you're active money manager
there. No matter how you slice the data,
historically by style, by geography,
active money managers have struggled to
match up to the index. And across all
time periods, the underperformance is
not just there, but it's rampant. It's
big. You can't ignore it. And even in
emerging and smaller markets, at least
in theory, active money managers should
have an advantage, it's not there. Now,
if you're puzzled as to why this might
be happening, how come all this brain
power and data and tools don't pay off
in higher returns, we will talk about
what it is that's beeviling active
investing and why it's becoming more
difficult over time to actually be an
active investor in the next session or
two. I hope you found the session useful
and I thank you very much for listening.